la differenza che c'è tra me e Carlo
Conti oltre la abbronzatura Secondo voi
qual è
è che Carlo su questo palco sarebbe
tranquillissimo nessuna
nessun battito veloce nessuna voce
tremante nessuno le mani sudate però se
io e Carlo domani ci buttassimo giù da
un aereo molto probabilmente Proveremo
entrambi le stesse cose battito veloce
respira affannato mani sudate voce
tremante e muscoli tesi ciò che ci
accomuna e che ci rende simili di fronte
a situazioni percepite come
preoccupanti o stressanti è la risposta
psicofisica Infatti prima di capire che
cos'è il coraggio forse dovremmo capire
che cos'è la paura la paura da un punto
di vista delle neuroscienze affettive è
un'emozione un'emozione che si innesta
Appunto proprio quando siamo davanti a
situazioni che noi personalmente
percepiamo come pericolose
immaginiamo di essere in una foresta
Stiamo camminando e d'improvviso arriva
un orso
l'immagine dell'Orso arriva direttamente
al nostro cervello in particolar modo
Attiva un'area del cervello che è
responsabile per l'elaborazione delle
emozioni quest'area si chiama amigdala
una volta che l'amigdala ha elaborato le
informazioni uditiva e visiva Invia un
messaggio di soccorso all'ipotalamo
l'ipotalamo deve essere un po' preso
come un centro di comando che comunica
con il resto del corpo attraverso il
sistema nervoso autonomo in questo caso
il sistema nervoso autonomo è il sistema
nervoso simpatico
Esso Attiva tramite una serie di eventi
a cascata la risposta lotta e Fuggi
Fight or flight questa risposta ci
permette di agire immediatamente manda
energia al cuore al cervello e ai
muscoli
l'adrenalina inizia a pompare nel sangue
e porta con sé una serie di cambiamenti
il battito cardiaco va più veloce la
pressione sanguigna aumenta il flusso
sanguigno viene deviato verso i
principali gruppi muscolari le piccole
vie aeree si spalancano
i polmoni iniziano ad assorbire quanto
più ossigeno possibile per rendere il
nostro cervello più vigile
il cervello sposta l'attenzione dalla
fase in cui era Rest and daijust riposa
e digerisci per permetterci di
congelarci
scappare o combattere Se questa è la
vostra scelta di fronte a un orso
se siamo davanti a un orso questo ci
permette di salvarci la vita che cosa
succede però quando ci troviamo davanti
a situazioni che noi percepiamo come
pericolose ma che in realtà non sono
veramente pericolose
Io su questo palco sono in lotta e fuggi
questo palco è il mio orso allo stesso
modo il vostro esame o il vostro capo
che mi che vi chiama per un colloquio
l'insegnante che richiama alla cattedra
possono essere il vostro orso
l'amigdala non è in grado di capire se
un pericolo è reale oppure no la
risposta Fighter flight lotta e Fuggi è
talmente rapida talmente veloce che la
parte razionale del nostro cervello non
è in grado di dare una spiegazione
logica alla situazione
Esiste un modo però per riprendere il
controllo e non perdere il controllo
della situazione
una delle tecniche più usate per uscire
dalla lotta e Fuggi Quindi da
attivazione simpatica è la meditazione
la meditazione è una tecnica
studiatissima sono moltissimi gli studi
che dimostrano i benefici della
meditazione pensate che è talmente utile
e importante che Alcune regioni e alcuni
stati hanno deciso di introdurla
all'interno delle scuole per insegnarla
fin da piccoli
esiste Però qualcosa che secondo me
dovrebbe essere insegnato prima della
meditazione
qualcosa che in realtà sta alla base
della meditazione
qualcosa che sta alla base di tutte le
tecniche di rilassamento dello Yoga e
del Tai Chi
la vita inizia e finisce con esso
l'umanità ancora prima della Scienza
aveva capito la sua importanza non solo
per la sopravvivenza Ma per il benessere
psicofisico
lo facciamo più di 20.000 volte al
giorno
lo state facendo anche ora e lo sto
facendo anche io magari qualcuno ha
capito
la respirazione
ora voi vi starete chiedendo che cosa
c'è esattamente da imparare tutti
nasciamo con la capacità di fare respiri
profondi ingaggiando completamente il
diaframma il muscolo principe della
respirazione
crescendo però e invecchiando tutto
dallo stress della vita quotidiana
all'ossessione di tirare in dentro la
pancia ci porta ad avere una
respirazione sempre più alta più
toracica meno soddisfacente e più
superficiale
il modo in cui respiriamo invece può
fare davvero la differenza
infatti la respirazione
Controlla il sistema nervoso autonomo
il sistema nervoso autonomo è formato da
due parti antagoniste il dottor Jekyll e
il Mister Hyde del nostro organismo
il sistema simpatico di cui abbiamo
parlato prima responsabile della
risposta lotta e Fuggi e il suo fratello
più simpatico in realtà del
parasimpatico il sistema parasimpatico
responsabile della risposta Rest E dai
Gest riposa e digerisci la respirazione
in grado di attivarne uno o l'altro e
l'attivazione di uno comporta la
soppressione dell'altro
pensate che se fosse minimamente etico
potrei indurvi ad avere un attacco di
panico infatti la respirazione veloce
superficiale può provocare un attacco di
panico oppure peggiorarne uno già in
corso aumentando quindi i livelli di
ansia
al contrario una respirazione lenta
profonda controllata che Come si può
dire suo dire di pancia ci permette di
attivare il sistema parasimpatico
ed è affascinante scoprire che è proprio
qui dove ho la mia mano tra il torace e
gli addominali che si trova uno degli
ingressi al nostro sistema parasimpatico
il coraggio la chiave per il coraggio
Infatti attraverso il diaframma passa un
nervo molto importante il nervo vago il
nervo vago si chiama nervo vago perché
vaga per tutto il corpo parte dalla
testa e arriva all'intestino Esso regola
e misura l'attività di moltissimi organi
interni
Quando il nervo vago viene stimolato la
pace pervade il corpo
il battito cardiaco rallenta
la pressione sanguigna diminuisce i
muscoli si rilassano
ed è sempre il nervo vago che va a
informare il cervello di questi
cambiamenti
aumentando la sensazione di pace
quindi più muoviamo la pancia e
smettiamo di tirarla indietro più
lasciamo spazio al diaframma di muoversi
e più il diaframma si muoverà Maggiore
sarà l'attivazione del nervo vago e più
il nervo vago verrà attivato Maggiore
sarà l'attivazione parasimpatica e
quindi l'accesso al nostro coraggio
esistono altri modi in realtà per
stimolare l'attivazione vagale e
l'attività del diaframma una è la
medicina più antica del mondo
la risata Infatti ridere Non solo
rilascia effettivamente endorfine ma ci
permette meccanicamente di stimolare il
nervo vago bastano 5 minuti di una
commedia divertente per attivare il
sistema parasimpatico
un altro metodo è il canto che voi siate
intonati stonati che cantiate dentro la
doccia o fuori dalla doccia Questo vi
permette di attivare il sistema
parasimpatico e vi dirò di più se siete
sotto la doccia e state cantando girate
la manipola verso l'acqua fredda Infatti
l'acqua fredda ci permette di attivare
il nervo vago e quindi la risposta
parasimpatica
Ecco forse cantare e ridere durante un
esame Non è proprio la scelta più
indicata allo stesso modo farmi la
doccia fredda su un palco o quando mi
sto buttando giù insieme a Carlo dal
paracadute non sembrano proprio le
tecniche migliori o più comode sapete
invece cos'è comodo gratuito sempre a
portata di mano o meglio di pancia
la respirazione Infatti basta un solo
minuto di respirazione lente profonda
per attivare il sistema parasimpatico e
i ricercatori ci dicono che questo
minuto va sfruttato al meglio respirando
circa 6 volte in un minuto e gli ultimi
studi suggeriscono di concentrarci su un
aspetto specifico della respirazione
ovvero l'espirazione il buttare fuori
inspirando per 4 secondi
e buttando fuori per 6 Quindi se avete
bisogno di coraggio se siete su un palco
se siete un esame espirate espirate
profondamente infatti durante
l'espirazione la frequenza cardiaca
diminuisce e questo ha un effetto
calmante sul cuore e per estensione sul
cervello
ora direte tutto bellissimo sappiamo
respirare abbiamo imparato a respirare
però a volte le cose sembrano più grandi
di noi e anche un compito così semplice
come respirare anche se respirare
profondamente completamente può sembrare
complesso
anche in questo caso la scienza ci dà
una mano infatti la respirazione non
solo può essere insegnata e imparata ma
può essere anche allenata infatti
possiamo allenare la respirazione tutti
i giorni e in qualsiasi momento
invece di scrollare Instagram o tic toc
Invece di prendere il Millesimo caffè
della giornata o fumare la ventesima
sigaretta
Provate a prendervi un momento
proviamo a farlo ora
chiudiamo gli occhi
portiamo le spalle in alto e indietro
allunghiamo la colonna vertebrale verso
l'alto
portiamo una mano sul petto e una mano
sul ventre
e osserviamo semplicemente quello che
succede al corpo quando gli permettiamo
di stare immobili
Ora proviamo a immaginare un piccolo
palloncino al di sotto dell'ombelico
ogni volta che inspiriamo
il palloncino si gonfia e allontana la
mano dal corpo
ogni volta che espiriamo il palloncino
si sgonfia
Ora proviamo lentamente
a gonfiare e sgonfiare il palloncino
inspiriamo per 4
e buttiamo fuori per 6
inspiro 1
espiro 5 4
inspiro 2
espiro 5 4 3
espiro 5 4
battito lento
respiro profondo
voce tranquilla
mani asciutte e muscoli rilassati
Grazie
[Applauso]